a little ladies and gentlemen my name is
ryan right welcome two reasons to see
where i'll provide you with movie news
in three minutes or less based on movie
articles that i found interesting Daniel
Craig's role in star wars the force
awakens might have been revealed by
Simon Pegg when he was being kind of an
idiot he flat out said Daniel Craig was
a stormtrooper surprise ruin x-files is
getting a six-episode return to Fox
where it will be debuting would possibly
Fox's largest audience after the NFL NFC
Championship game if there's one thing I
know about NFL fans is that they all
love the x-files another film based off
the fugitive is in the works the
original fugitives start Harrison Ford
and Tommy Lee Jones we don't even know
if it's a sequel or a rebooter remake we
don't know what it is all we know is
Hollywood is still running out of ideas
alex garland writer of 28 days later has
revealed that he has an idea for 28
months later although alex is not so
fond of sequels he did say that sequels
are done in a rush but he also forgot
that if you wait too long nobody gives a
[ __ ] anymore according to Collider the
next planet of the apes film will be
called war of the Planet of the Apes I
wonder what this one's gonna be about
according to Variety Diego Luna has
landed a lead role and Star Wars rogue
one in the force awakens we get a black
guy front and center and now in Star
Wars Row 1 we get a latino guy front and
center for the next one I would love to
see in Armenian be the lead in a Star
Wars film why because Armenians have not
only never been casted in a Star Wars
movie but they've never been casted in
an American film before the director of
Selma is being considered to direct one
of two Marvel movies either black
panther or Captain Marvel from seeing a
strong biopic of Martin Luther King jr.
and not knowing who black panther or
Captain Marvel art I can see how this
will be a great success in Marvel
Javier Bardem and Penelope Cruz are set
to star in a biopic about Pablo Escobar
Pablo Escobar was one of the most
powerful drug cartel kingpins of all
time and I personally was able to buy
from him once anyway guys that's it for
the movie news that i found interesting
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
follow us on facebook instagram or
twitter and you could catch a good
amount of my videos on latino review com
an amazing sight that is dedicated to
people who like movies those same people
masturbate a lot sorry latina review one
day I will give you a really positive
plug hot plug